police stop and search powers are to be
restored to try to combat knife crime
the home secretary said the use of stop
and search had taken 50 000 weapons off
the streets over the past three years
but the independent office for police
conduct watchdog said the black people
were seven times more likely to be
stopped and searched than white people
and asian people were two and a half
times more likely well let's go live to
north london where we can talk to ken
hines executive member of haran gay
independent stop and search monitoring
group
and can you just explain just a little
bit about your group and what evidence
you've gathered
yeah well what we are we are grassroot
group and what we do
we
we monitor and interact with the police
around stop and search holding them to
account on behalf of our community so we
support our
young vulnerable people in and bringing
complaints against the police when they
think that they've been unfairly
targeted or unfairly stopped um we
support them
when they're going through the court
legal system if they believe that they
have been wrongfully um
charged with an offence of usually
assault or obstruction of police when
it's usually it beggars believe that
you've got no criminal record so why are
you going to try to attack a police in
doing an interaction that's supposed to
be able to allay or confirm their
suspicion about you but doing any kind
of wrongdoing
sorry kevin
i've been also well aware that 80
percent of their stopping certs lead to
those further action
i was just going to say that the home
secretary says that it leads to knives
coming off the streets and that isn't
this isn't going to be a universal uh
rolling out of stock and searches it's
going to be in specific areas at
specific times does that give you any
reassurance not at all because we've
been here before under section 16
section 60 doesn't mean there's no
suspicion they don't need to have any
suspicion about stopping and searching
you but what what we've seen in the past
when theresa may was there and what she
recognized what it did it created a
culture of lazy policing where the
police didn't had to throw out the
rulebook around reasonable suspicion and
and about professionalism when they come
across a stop and search now to me it's
smacks of desperation now again i
understand and i'm i'm with the home
secretary
in wanting to find a better way of
getting more knives and guns off our
street and i will question that 50 000
of weapon searches that have been taken
off the street because if their own
figure says that in one year they took
off 300 nights after 20 000 searches
that that is less than one night per
week
per borough
which is a very poor return because we
get a better return when grassroot
groups
interact with the young people and get
them to drop the tape then um to stop
carrying knives
and that and and would you say that that
is the better way
what is the better way of of stopping
knife crime in your view it's a
combination of deterrent i believe
strongest strongest sentencing less
tolerant for people carrying knives and
also diversity that is working as
supporting and resourcing grassroots
groups that's dealing directly or
interacting with the with the young
people who are more likely going to be
caught up in that kind of vicious circle
we've got to break that cycle and we're
not going to break it by giving
police the power to to do something that
they're not very good at doing they're
not very good at communicating or not
very good at de-escalating and they
definitely have not got the confidence
on the black community about the way
that they are actually conducting a stop
and search let me say this much at the
height of section 60 back in
2013-2014 2014
as a black person
you we were as on a section six on this
pace that we were six seven times more
like we stopped and searched but under
section 16 we were 20 times more likely
to be stopped and searched so what do
you think is going to improve this time
around
unless we have greater transparency and
accountability the mayor's office he's
got an action plan he recognized that
what the police are doing aren't doing
it quite right and aren't quite doing it
quite effectively and he's setting up a
whole monitoring group to see the
effectiveness of that sort of police
thing
do you think stop and search could make
the situation worse rather than better
when they're saying worse we're already
saying that four out of five stops and
search lead to no further action but the
interaction with young people could lead
to that young person being what we call
stockton scarred and when they're
stopped and scarred they're less likely
to turn to the police for any kind of
support and and their and their trauma
also becomes their family and friends
trauma and they're less likely to engage
in the police when you know serious
crimes being committed don't get me
wrong we have got issues and and people
often say is well it's black youngsters
um attacking other black youngsters so
we're there as victims and also as
perpetrators but so why are we going to
the establishment to try to find um a
way out of this when we should be coming
to people like myself who's in the black
community and has some influence to to
better results us so that we can
actually do a more effective work in our
community okay ken hines from harrengay
stop and search monitoring thank you
very much